good morning nathan tannenbaum we're
starting in the traffic center because
this is a huge heads up the southbound
95 has been closed in the northwest
valley for six hours this started at 12
30 this morning so huge heads up
centennial hills aliante sky canyon if
you use the 95 to get into town
you can't do that this motorcycle
crashed 12 30 this morning a single
vehicle motorcycle crash according to
nevada highway patrol so earlier the
closure was not really affecting traffic
but here we are at 6 30 and we got a lot
of folks trying to use that frontage
road but you're going to end up kind of
tangled up behind the santa fe so
investigators are still on scene we got
folks in hazmat suits walking around the
freeway so the south 95 is completely
closed how are you going to get around
it i would skip the 95 from aliante take
the 215 to jones jones down to craig
gets you onto the 95. centennial hills
sky point 95 to the 215 to durango
durango down to craig and then on to the
95. don't know when it's going to reopen
we'll keep you posted in the meantime
you got to make your plans for holiday
weather and